what I've got here is the graph of y is
equal to cosine of X and what I want to
do is figure out the area under the
curve Y is equal to f of X and above the
x-axis I'm going to do it over various
intervals so first let's think about the
area under the curve between X is equal
to zero and X is equal to PI over two x
is equal to PI over two so we're talking
about this area this area right over
here well the way we denote it is the
definite integral from 0 to PI over 2 of
cosine of X DX and all this is is kind
of it's reminiscent of taking a sum of a
bunch of super thin rectangles with
width DX and height f of X at each if
for each of those rectangles and then
you take an infinite number of those
infinitely thin rectangles and that's
kind of what this notation is trying to
depict but we know how to do this
already the second fundamental theorem
of calculus helps us we just have to
figure out what the antiderivative of
cosine of X is or what an antiderivative
of cosine of X is evaluated at PI over 2
and from that subtract it evaluated at 0
so what's the antiderivative of cosine
of X or what's an antiderivative well we
know if we take the derivative let me
write this up here we know that if we
take the derivative of sine of X sine of
X we get cosine of X so the
antiderivative of cosine of X is sine of
X now why do I keep saying sine of X is
an antiderivative it's not just the
antiderivative well I can also take the
antiderivative of sine of X sine of X
plus any arbitrary constant and still
get cosine of X because the derivative
of a constant is 0 this could be PI this
could be 5 this could be a million this
could be Google this could be any crazy
number but the derivative of this is
still going to be cosine X so when I say
that we just have to we have to find an
antiderivative I'm just saying look we
just have to find one of the derivatives
sine of X is probably the simplest
because in this case the constant is 0
so let's evaluate so one way that we can
denote this the antiderivative of cosine
of X where an antiderivative of cosine
of X is sine of X and we're going to
evaluate it at PI over 2 and from that
subtract it evaluated at 0 so this is
going to be equal to let me do it right
over here this is going to be equal to
sine of PI over 2 minus sine of 0 which
is equal to sine of PI over 2 is 1 sine
of 0 is 0 so it's 1 minus 0 is equal to
1 so the area of this region right over
here this area is equal to 1 now let's
do something interesting let's think
about the area let's think about the
area under the curve between let's think
about the curve area under the curve
between let's say PI over 2 PI over 2
and 3 PI over 2 3 3 PI over 2 3 PI over
2 3 PI over 2 so between here and here
so we're talking about this area we're
talking about that area right over here
this is 3 PI over 2 so once again the
way we denote the area is the definite
integral from PI over 2 to 3 PI over 2
of cosine of X DX the antiderivative or
n antiderivative of cosine of X is sine
of X evaluated at 3 PI over 2 and PI
over 2 so this is going to be equal to
sine of 3 PI over 2 minus sine of PI
over 2 what's sine of 3 PI over 2 if you
visualize the unit circle if we
visualize the unit circle real fast 3 PI
over 2 is going all the way 3 fourths
around the unit circle so it's right
over there
so sine is Z is the y-coordinate on that
unit circle so it's negative 1 so this
right over here is negative 1 this right
over your sine of PI over 2 PI over 2 is
just going straight up like that so sine
of PI over 2 is 1 so this is interesting
we get negative 1 minus 1 which
equal to negative two we got a negative
area here we got a negative area now how
does that make sense we know in the real
world areas are always positive but what
is negative two really trying to depict
well it's trying to sign it for the
based on the idea that now our function
is below the x-axis so we could kind of
think that we have an area of two but
it's all below the x-axis in this case
and so it is signed as negative to the
actual area is two but since it's below
the x-axis we get a negative right over
here now let's do one more interesting
one let's find the definite integral
from 0 to 3 PI over 2 0 to 3 PI over 2
of cosine of X DX now this is just
denoting this entire area going from 0
all the way all the way to 3 PI over 2
and what do you think is going to happen
well let's evaluate it it's going to be
sine of 3 PI over 2 sine of 3 PI over 2
minus sine of 0 minus sine of 0 which is
equal to negative 1 minus 0 which is
equal to negative 1 so what just
happened here the area under all this
orange area that I just outlined is
clearly not negative or any area isn't a
negative number and there isn't even one
but what just happened here
well we saw in the first case that this
first area that this first area was 1
the area of this first region right over
here is 1 and then the area of the
second region we got negative 2 we got
negative 2 negative 2 and so one way to
interpret it is is that your net area
above your net area above the x-axis is
negative 1 or you another way to say it
your net area is negative 1 so it's
taking the one might one air one region
above the x-axis and then subtracting
the two below it so what the definite
integral is doing when we evaluate it
using the second fundamental theorem of
calculus it's essentially finding the
net area above the x
axes and if we get a negative number
that means that the net area is that
actually most of the area is below the
x-axis if we get zero then that means it
all Nets out and if you want to see a
case that's zero take the integral from
from zero all the way all the way to two
pi and this will evaluate to zero
because you have an area of one and in
another area of one but it nets out with
this area of negative two let's try that
out so if we go from zero to two pi of
cosine of X DX this is going to be equal
to sine of two pi minus sine of zero
which is equal to zero minus zero which
is indeed equal to zero now clearly
there was area here but all the area
that was above the x-axis netted out
with all the area that was below the
x-axis